so let's get into uh past to wealth uh
and past that are I guess the first
thing we should talk about is pasts that
aren't going to get you uh wealthy or
Rich and I'm going to save you years of
wasting your time because I spent the
better part of the first 30 odd years of
my life making the mistakes that just
about everybody makes um I don't know
when did I start working I think I
was I was about nine years old maybe
eight or something paper root you know
my dad said uh because I wanted an
allowance because all my friends got an
allowance and you know they were getting
25 cents 50 cents a week uh obviously
dating myself yes I'm a a seasoned
gentleman a little bit older but um yeah
he wasn't about that and he's like yeah
if you want to make some money then go
out and make it shovel driveways cut
grass uh you know go deliver papers and
he set me up with this route and I
remember very vividly they were paying
like half a cent per delivery to the
house uh I didn't think it was possible
to get half a cent for doing something
but literally from walking from one
house to another house from one door to
another they paid half a cent to drop
that thing on the front porch so I
started early um I think I got my first
part-time job in high school um or
leading up to probably grade eight
grocery store bagging carry up boy you
know getting uh shopping carts and stuff
like that and they were paying about
265 $265 an hour uh so you know these
are all hourly gigs right and the plan
at the time was you know you would do
these things but you didn't have any
expenses as a kid you didn't have to pay
for food or rent or mortgages or
utilities or any of these things you
just made the money you kept it only I
didn't because my parents forced me to
pay rent by the time I was about 15 they
called it rent but it was more of a
contribution to the household at the end
of the day uh they gave me some money as
a small down payment towards my first
house so I probably got everything back
that I paid them in my teen years so um
you know it's a washut sense but at the
end of the day um yeah I didn't really
have that much left over but it but it
did pile up and then this notion of oh
now I've got some money starting to
accumulate whether it was a $100 and you
get to your first $100 you get to your
first thousand you get to your first
$2,000 you know so on and so forth then
you know the notion of wealth being
created starts to conjure up ideas in
your head
and uh that's not really how it works
out though right um because even as I
progress through making more and more
hourly and as you make more and more
here in Canada they tax you on a sliding
scale so the lowest tax rate uh I think
it's under 35,000 right now maybe 40,000
or something like that it was probably
closer to 26 or 28,000 when I was a
young man um the lowest tax rate they
barely tax you you know you pay almost
nothing in taxes and they start to stack
the tax rate higher and higher the more
you make more money so you know that was
like one of the first redpilling moments
for for me you know unplugging from
those lies was yeah Chase Excellence to
make more money and you'll always have
more money only you didn't because the
more money you made the more they would
tax you which is funny as hell because
I'm the guy that says Chase Excellence
not women but the government itself the
way that they've structured the taxation
system is they've structured it in such
a way that they discourage you from
chasing Excellence because the more
money you make the more money you pay in
taxes so you arguably have to work
harder and I mean there's ways to work
smarter obviously but you have to work
harder to earn more of that money and
keep it and deal with it in a more
intelligent way as you start to
accumulate it so I guess by my 20s I
started to realize you know I had more
than one car at that time i' gone
through a couple of cars I was probably
on my second or third motorcycle by then
uh I was riding sport bikes so
Summertime with sport bikes winter time
I had a car car was usually a piece of
[__] uh sport bikes was you know where
all the fun was had and I think um I was
in England for four or five months
because my parents went back I was about
2122 or something like that didn't like
it there and I came back to Canada got
another job job by the way is an acronym
JB stands for just over broke never
forget that whenever you go out there
and you get a job anywhere it's
engineered and I think more so today
than any other time in history because
you can go back to to my granddad's era
and my great granddad's era and for them
they had a very very nice life uh
comparatively speaking to today's uh
inflation adjusted with a nice house
paid off for a family everything was
taken care of uh my nana on my dad's
side know my grandmother in the UK would
have stayed home uh she didn't work uh
great-grandfather as well so arguably
back then you could have a j o uh you'd
stay with the same company like my
granddad you know for example he worked
with the Royal Air Force for pretty much
forever uh and then when he did his uh
his time and he was able to get out and
retire and get his pension he started
doing random things he opened up a pub
and a few other things like that um but
they live quite well back then
comparatively speaking to today so
having a job again just over broke is
really just over broke today um there
are certain jobs that do pay well
I'll be completely honest with you and
I'll get into paths that create wealth
you moment but for example um I do a lot
of private consults um if you guys are
interested you know you can find my
stuff on the website at Rich
[Music]
cooper.com that you know became quite
noticeable when you're dealing with
these guys is the way that they
structure their lives and manage their
money and their cash flow and everything
sort of tied around that is is
exponentially different like um an
engineer for example that might work at
one of the Fang companies if you don't
know what Fang is it's like uh what is
it Facebook Amazon Apple Netflix Google
it's f a NG it's a common acronym known
in the tech world and some of these guys
they'll make $800 $900,000 a year like
as an employees having a j o like a job
so so there's some exceptions to the
rule right so I'll get into the paths
that do create wealth in a moment but
the vast majority of the ones that
you're going to find like 95 90% of the
stuff out there where see these reports
in the news in the media or social media
and you know they're all oh the job
numbers are up there's more jobs than
ever before there's more people you know
employed than ever before blah blah blah
yeah but they're still broke as [__]
right the even with the minimum wage
going up I don't even know what it is
today right now here it's probably about
15 bucks an hour or something like that
it depends on the province but you know
again when I was a kid it was like 275
so in around 15 bucks you know we'll
call it these kids they don't have I'm
calling them kids but you know these
young men and women they don't have
enough money to really live in the kind
of way they want that's why you see you
know young girls today turning to things
like only fans to sell pictures of
themselves to creeps online simps you
know we'll just call them simps uh you
know the simps online uh to try to you
know pay bills and make ends meet or
they'll get sugar daddies and they'll go
and get involved with older guys
whatever and a lot of these guys you
know they're they're struggling you know
and the hustle with a a job j o just
over broke generally doesn't cut it for
most people um I had a
conversation briefly with a guy in one
of my junior
communities and there's a challenge that
came up and some of you guys watching
right now might be in that in that group
um and it's a fitness challenge and moff
is organizing and he's like you know we
need everybody to buy in and then you
know the pock gets paid out sort of
thing and there's always you know like a
more unseason guy a junior guy he's in
his early 20s and he's like well it's
100 bucks to buy well you know let me do
it next week when I got my paycheck and
I was like for [__] sakes you know
trying to organize these things and put
it together and not being able to scrape
together like 100 bucks to me is a huge
red flag there's something wrong in your
life if you have to wait till the next
paycheck um you know if somebody says to
me that's in one of my more senior tiers
where guys are are seasoned or should at
least be seasoned and have their life
sorted out they're into their 30s and
40s and they say something like yeah I
want to come to your conference ritual I
gota I gota wait till like November 10th
or something like that I'll grab a
ticket then it's like wrong room you
know
um
the the indicator to you should be your
ability to buy your purchasing power
your ability to maneuver your ability to
make choices and decisions your ability
to acquire things to buy yourself in the
room uh you know to take the vacations
you want to take the time off you want
to drive the car that you want there's
so many guys out there right now that
are living paycheck paycheck they're
just over broke job and you know they're
thinking that if I just work a little
bit more if I have a little extra income
somewhere a side hustle if I go drive
Uber or Lyft or something like that I
looked at the economics of uber and Lyft
um when that came out I was I was
genuinely interested right like I'm like
huh that's interesting you know we have
this decentralized economy now
where The Gatekeepers to certain
industries have all been removed if you
want to publish a book you can do it on
Amazon I did right I didn't need I
didn't need the help of any publisher to
put this out there and I've sold I don't
know 150,000 like lots and lots of
copies of this [__] like there's loads
of these copies out there and I didn't
need anybody's permission I just did it
I put it on there I mean you know you
have a guy on Fiverr you know do the
design you want to start up a podcast
you can upload it to Spotify you want to
start up a taxi company you can get a
car and drive for Uber sort of thing um
you want to become a hotel year uh you
acquire some property and put it on
Airbnb and rented out right there's
there's there's Gatekeepers in the past
that have been dismissed they've been
removed um you want to start up start up
a TV show YouTube you don't have to go
to a a cable station and do any of that
stuff anymore so again J OBS just over
broke will not do it do it for a short
period of time there's certain scenarios
where it may be advantageous to do it
like for example um I didn't know that I
was going to start up a debt settlement
company but the fact that I worked in
credit and collections for I don't know
what was it eight nine 10 years
somewhere between eight and uh 10 years
but for the most part of my 20s I
learned the industry like a back of my
hand right I started as you know the guy
in the phone in the call center became a
supervisor became a branch manager uh
ended up
doing all of my reporting into the Vice
President in the region got to spend
some time mentoring with the president
of the company so I got involved in all
kinds of programs there so as you sort
of climb the corporate ladder like if
you're going to work at J O climb the
corporate ladder for [__] sakes like
make sure your your opportunity to
progress and move up occurs it may not
always occur within the same company
sometimes you have to leave that company
to go to a competitor to get paid what
you're worth there's a an old saying
that employers use and it's one business
owner speaking to another business owner
and they say how much do you pay an
employee and the answer is as little as
possible that is the angle that the
employer approaches it from I need to
pay this guy as little as I possibly can
because I have overhead rent I'm have a
building I have to pay for mortgage
insurance Eno accounting department
legal fees like they have all of these
expenses and there has to be profit
there for them so the angle for most
employers is pay people as little as
they possibly have to that's why you see
a lot of these corporations now um like
McDonald's for example announced in the
last uh year or so that they're opening
up locations that are fully automated
they don't need anybody flipping burgers
putting fries in the fryer it's all
robotic 247 nobody calls in sick nobody
gets pregnant nobody's [__] anybody
and complained to HR there's none of
that stuff they deal with none of the uh
deleterious consequences of having
employees in the organization and
they've been running this experiment and
I think what you're going to see is more
and more locations either retrofited or
converted or all new locations are going
to be robotic um I don't know if it'll
all be drive-thru or you walk in or
whatever you push a button and some [__]
will pop up through a [__] escalator
or an elevator it's like here's your
fries and happy meal or whatever so
you you're going to start seeing more
and more of that which is going to lead
to more automation more Robotics and
fewer people working and then you've got
these socialists in the government that
are saying keep raising minimum wage and
then employers are like [__] that I
can't pay you know somebody 25 bucks to
flip a burger that means it's going to
cost somebody coming to my restaurant
you know $30 for a b and the inflation
just keeps driving it up so you know
this whole vicious cycle of what goes on
with government policy versus Company's
trying to respond to it to make a profit
because make no mistake you're a
publicly traded company your job is to
return a profit you have a fiduciary
duty to return a profit to your
shareholders you cannot [__] that up if
you [__] that up you lose shareholders
you lose market share your stock price
drops you as a CEO the seet jobs in that
realm ain't going to be sitting in those
seats next year it is what it is I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clip's from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out